hi thank you so I guess a little bit
more about my background I am a trained
educator and facilitator I've run
professional development workshops for
teachers and artists who teach in the
schools in public schools in New York
City I also worked with students
directly of all ages from pre-k through
high school and I currently teach
English as a Second Language right now
part time at a local English language
school as far as engineering and data
science I am pretty much self-taught
although I feel a little strange saying
self-taught because I really learned
programming and architectures within the
community in New York and both the
programming community the startup
community and technology at large in New
York City so I'm very grateful to have
had that opportunity I actually took a
hiatus from teaching odd and I guess it
was 2000 between 2004 and 2005 and for a
while I worked in at a at an integral
integrated marketing agency and I did
that right up until the Great Recession
hit which and of course at that time I
still wanted to stay active and engaged
I was also becoming very interested in
social media so I continue to do that
while things were pretty slow and I
became even more excited about the way
that social media augmented what human
beings could do I'm the way that they
could connect with each other the way
that we could form and assert our
identities and just maintain connections
at one point I did start to become
concerned about the fact that although
at that point I was I was an adult I had
pretty good judgment about what I should
and shouldn't post online but with all
the care that I took to maintain my
privacy settings I realized that I had
absolutely no control over what the
startups at that time were doing to
protect my data and that so I became
really interested in privacy and what
kinds of processes we could put in place
to make sure that people's privacy was
being respected the same way that they
could kind of regulate what they were
exposing to the outside world so oh
actually I am happy to note that in the
past five years there's been a lot of a
lot of attention people have been paying
a lot of attention to privacy and proper
processes within their organizations and
even in government to make sure that we
were protecting each other online and
creating safe spaces for people to
interact also protecting personal data
which means that I could concentrate on
more bud or and other things that were
emerging such as I think when first when
social media first came out it was all
about content and we didn't know we
hadn't yet started analyzing that
content or analyzing people's behaviors
online so that's actually something that
brought me more into data science than
privacy
it all ends up connecting so along those
lines I I wanted to start exploring my
personal data and I thought that might
mean putting it all into one place which
also made me nervous because I felt like
I was I might just be creating a
honeypot for hackers and I didn't want
to do that either so I decided to create
a project that i call my little data in
a big data world which i had the
opportunity to kind of soft launch as a
poster at PI data 2015 and it describes
an early process of retrieving personal
data securing and exploring it and
identifying the tools that you'll that
you can use to start cultivating your
own identity not just by writing but by
looking at yourself in your digital form
so i guess i assume that most people use
social media but how many of you
actually do use social media how many of
you share information on social media
okay so most of you and how many of you
use email yeah the sort of a year I now
are do I'm guessing that a lot of you or
actually does anybody analyze social
media as part of your data science
practice or engineering okay some a
little bit okay this is good and what
about I think in general we don't
analyze email per se but there are some
anonymizing practices and machine
learning that is used and where data
science is applied to to help people do
things with email without necessarily
having humans read it so oh I skipped a
little bit so as data scientists of
course you want to look at data and come
up with the most objective analyses that
you can and sometimes part of your job
is to find information that can be used
in marketing and I found this little
tidbit on Twitter about what happens and
sometimes when we're using data and
marketing or how that ends up being used
can everyone see it okay now i have to
say that for this project my little data
i am interested in in letting people
know enough about how to access data
tools and how to use their own data so
that maybe they don't quite do that but
they can use data to make decisions
about maybe next steps in their lives so
for example you might analyze your
linkedin data you might look at your
your connections and the positions that
they've had where their work is
overlapped with your work or what you
might aspire to do and that might give
you some guidance about your next step
your next steps especially as the
economy changes pretty quickly
so of course the slide that you just saw
talked about or you know talk to showed
you a little bit about datum and if you
manipulation of bindings and data but of
course that this happens in politics or
school admissions or hiring decisions if
you're moving away from objectivity then
that can be a problem and one thing that
I thought might be important would be to
make data more accessible and make data
analysis more accessible so that as
people encounter decisions that are made
by some of the tools that we create as
engineers and data scientists that that
people know enough to actually be able
to evaluate those things from a personal
perspective and I think some interesting
things can happen once that interplay
comes to life
so this is kind of a presentation within
a presentation of course I talked about
my little data in a big data world and
the process that I used last year as a
you know very much a beginner was to
look at the tools that were already
pretty accessible so here you have a
word cloud which most people are
familiar with you go to a website you
put some texts in and it spits how these
images that show you what these images
show you we have an alarm these the
images show you they correlate with the
most frequent word usage then as I was
preparing for pi data 2015 I came across
this example actually I came across this
example of us unemployment data from
boghei plots so this was just a sample
that I thought I might hack and display
information about my from my Twitter
feed or Facebook or LinkedIn now as I
tried to create this entry level
experience for I guess burgeoning data
sciences or a citizen data science the
data scientist I wanted to take a look
at what might cause friction and in my
own experience the information that was
online for someone with limited
knowledge of both software engineering
and data was full of jargon I also
wanted to be aware of how much personal
day
a war being what's being exposed to the
web and also thought processes I haven't
well I'll get to that in a little bit
and I also didn't want to just create a
project where people were putting more
data out there because they were just in
the process of understanding just
beginning the process of understanding I
also noticed that most of the
documentation describes how to pull
information from api's so for example
there was a lot Twitter had a ton of
information about what was available
behind the scenes but you had to do it
through api's which meant that your
thought process was being exposed to
strangers and again that's data that
you're producing that you haven't had a
chance to engage yourself and that
you're not you haven't really had a
prior can stew process I also thought
that any precautions that you might take
so if you try to handle all of that
while you were also while you should
just be exploring it might just delay
you even starting a project so another
problem that I wanted to help beginner
salt was how to get their data and I
found I decided to just work with
Twitter that's where I was able to pull
down my data and it was as simple as
going to that link clicking a download
button and I think the first time I did
it it took maybe an hour to
and since then I've done it maybe every
six months or so and it only took no
more than two minutes to get the rest of
my data I also did LinkedIn and Google
Google took a bit longer and let's see
linkedin I think that was still within
the 12 to our range when I explored my
Twitter data I saw that one of the
reasons i chose social media data for
this project is that it's just already
out there and consumable by the public I
got it as a zip file Twitter so it was
encrypted by Twitter while in transit so
as someone who might be even though with
the social media information I wasn't so
concerned about privacy I did want to
think about it a little bit because I in
the long run I'd like I would like for
people to be able to explore more data
that is more personalized such as I
don't know if it but data health
information etc the file also had see us
it I actually like the way it packed it
was packaged so you could actually see
it was like your twitter homepage you
could search for keywords or words that
you might be interested in and find and
deliver the tweets that you actually
sent that had those words you could also
look at a CSV which could be converted
using Excel or I actually used
openoffice I think it's called open
calc because it was free and the data
type in the bouquet example that I
showed you earlier was also CSB so I
knew that I would be able to use the CSV
file to hack the bouquet plots example
also each word in a tweet has its own
column and that made that make counting
a lot easier or actually that's not
quite correct you you can put it sorry
into its own column which made counting
a lot easier and this is just a
screenshot of what the folder looks like
when you download it oh and my purse
tweet I talk a lot about cookies on
Twitter actually or just in general now
for a beginner to see what I had
produced on the internet and that format
was actually kind of fascinating for me
because I just had no idea what a tweet
looked like in the background and to
know enough to actually be able to find
and make that visual and mental
connection between this and the
experience the user experience that I
was having with Twitter or with social
media in general was also pretty
exciting for me oh and there it is
as I mentioned before I used openoffice
calc as a problem-solving tool it was
easy for just for me to see and
understand that layout because I'd been
using Excel for a few years oh and
dependencies so again this goes back to
looking at friction that might cause
beginners to abandon their projects and
data a lot I started off working with
windows and Python and I believe there
was a talk earlier today about fixing
windows which I I can't wait to see the
video for that myself I actually did a
talk on breaking windows which actually
was how I was able to get past that and
basically a lot of the information that
was online at the time had to do with
how to use your mac with different
software then I learned about anaconda
which made it pretty easy to solve that
problem with dependencies so with the
experience i have now i know what the
error messages mean when i'm trying to
install a piece of software and you know
my screen yells at me but back then i
would see this error message and someone
would say we'll just google the answer
which kind of worked but it's much
better if you don't have to do that so
having something like anaconda which
resolves a lot of that was great and
even as I hacked around with this a
little bit before giving the talk I was
still able to make the updates to my to
my lips to the local versions of this
without without having to Google much
word cloud I mentioned this a little bit
of course this is another way to get a
sense of what's in your data and my goal
in this particular project was just to
visualize or have find an interesting
way to present what I talked about most
on Twitter and I was able to do that
pretty quickly with a word cloud but of
course my other goal was to practice
programming hacking a little bit and
this is where i found that that's the
tool that I used I've mentioned bouquet
a few times it's it actually solved a
few problems for me and I'll just let
you read those overall it just seemed to
connect very closely to a process that I
was already pretty familiar with to
excel for example the code wasn't that
complicated and the visually the
visualization I chose I just liked how
it looked and that again is the visual
inspiration actually though as i was
looking at this I started thinking more
about natural language processing and
how you might incorporate color coding
into maybe a sentiment analysis for
example I haven't gotten that far yet
but I think that's where data science
could actually play more of a role in
this
and now for the part that I talked about
and the introduction or that you might
have read about and the introduction to
this talk data past present and yet to
come Matt and I of course borrowed that
braising from A Christmas Carol so
personal storage in the past people had
some kind of filing system maybe it was
a shoebox maybe you had paper files you
know the manila folders you kept things
and drawers you had your own safe
and oh actually I wanted to talk a
little bit more about companies so
companies would pretty much do the same
thing right they would store your
information on paper and a filing
cabinet maybe a filing cabinet that
locked maybe there was a vault maybe
there was a door that locked somewhere
in the building and the big danger of
data being lost or getting into the
wrong hands and transit had to do with
male robberies what was it the pony
express the solution that I came up with
for this project is this is obviously
just my opinion but to remove the
friction of trying to encrypt or I'd
make your data safe of course the first
decision was to use data that was
already out there then to commute
compute behind the firewall that's
already on your system so that made
things easier for me I have a hard drive
that's encrypted via password as far as
storage and memory management go a 4
gigabyte USB was plenty two gigabytes
would have been fine even and that was
not just for the Twitter information but
for which my Twitter account has existed
since 2008 I think I had about four
thousand tweets at the time my facebook
account has existed since about that
same amount of time I actually put my
myspace data on the same USB
which I feel like was a bit of a coup to
get and I'm leaving one out Oh linkedin
also fit on there and I think I've had
that since 2007 so to me that feels like
a lot of data but it actually fits well
onto a USB and part of the reason even
though four gigabytes is not a lot of
space it is a lot of space on my
computer because I like to experiment a
lot and I think that a lot of people who
would be entering data science would be
doing a lot of or engineering software
programming would be doing a lot of
processing on their own machines and it
seems safe enough I didn't current
encrypt the USB Drive just because I
from what i read encryption does run
some risk of distorting your information
and corrupting files oh I don't want to
get to that yet so that being said I
think my my slides are a little bit out
of order so give me a second Oh actually
I do have a question for you all does
any is anyone interested and actually
downloading your personal data now like
looking at your personal data to see
what's there yeah okay so think about
where you have it so far i I've just
downloaded google linkedin and facebook
I don't have a bit bit but I would be
interested in see what what's available
there question
I actually had okay so that's a great
question he asked about sites where you
might not have an account so he wanted
to know how you would go about getting
data from places where you don't
necessarily have an account right now I
am Not sure that there there's
definitely no central place to get that
kind of information but when i get to
the part on data what is it personal
data yet to come i'll talk a little bit
about how we might change things in
order to make it easier to have even
more data about ourselves that is
currently just out of reach to us so
thank you for that alright so does
anyone here have has anyone here
explored their own personal data before
okay you have all right what have you
looked at so far
okay so you have an app called move just
mo ve o moves okay okay great so it
tracks how you move and where you go
very interesting anyone else and are you
able to download it as a package or how
is it how is the data presented to you
okay okay dude are there any limits on
how much of your data you can download
or okay so it's just a matter of what
you have access to through the API or
scraping okay very interesting so oh
let's see raise your hand again if you
would be interested in looking at your
social ah ok at your social media data
okay we have ten minutes left so what
I'm going to do now is talk a little bit
about the answer to your question and
then I'll just show you that quick
process of looking at I think I'll do I
wasn't going to but i think i will do
Twitter data in a few minutes just to
give you a cent well you've kind of seen
what you see it I'll do Facebook just to
give you a sense of what you see both
behind the scenes and of course the
general user interface that they provide
for you
so personal storage data future locking
the web open and I think that actually
gets directly at the question that the
gentleman asked about how to get
information about how you're using the
web even if you don't have an account
there actually before I get to this part
there actually are some plugins that you
can get from Mozilla I don't know them
off the top of my head but I can find
them after the talk if you'd like that
will show you your personal data they'll
it'll track sites that you've visited
and it'll let you know also and you can
download it but it's a lot more
complicated than a project like this you
can also I just lost my thought oh you
can look at your search history in a
pretty straightforward way but locking
open the web so the dream I have is for
individuals to actually be more in
control of their data so instead of some
outside entity determining how the
information travels or how your data
travels you actually end up being in
charge of how the information travels
some companies that are working on that
are using blockchain technology you have
the interplanetary system again using
the distributed web and I would even go
as far as saying the decentralized web I
make a distinction between distributed
and decentralized and that you can be a
central entity and have information
distributed but that central entity
which may not be the individual
still in control of how that data comes
and goes or they can still be in control
of how that data comes and goes
depending on the stack you're using
there are some companies and
organizations and even individuals who
are trying to make it so that computing
happens outside of their control and the
end the individual doesn't have to do
the computing but the individual
controls whether or not anybody has
access to it so whether or not the user
controls basically whether or not an
outside entity can get access to
information that makes any sense so the
examples I found we're storage made say
for the safe Network the collaborative
cloud which is I thought was interesting
because that is an organization company
and of course the interplanetary file
system so i'm not sure if that answered
your question really you know deeply but
it's getting there okay so and these are
just other questions that I had as
always working on this that's pretty
much the end of that part of the
presentation but i do want to walk you
through that quick process of
downloading your information from the
web it's actually just my personal
google account and since you've asked
about google i'll show you very quickly
i always found that the easiest way to
get information about downloading your
personal information was to google it or
you
look forward through a search engine
because I could never find it on the
pages on the help pages any other
questions while I look for that
I was actually surprised by how robust
linkedin was so most of the both
Facebook my spell Facebook MySpace and
Twitter just gave you information about
but you just got content so things that
you'd posted some of your connections
tweets retweets all that linked n
actually gave you some click through
information so you could start to
analyze your behavior oocytes that
people's sites that you'd visit it so
connection sites that you've visited I
jobs that you looked at articles that
you'd clicked
right rather than this where it's easy
okay okay yeah that's actually an area
that I'm very interested in and I I
can't go that deeply into it because
honestly I'm still learning about it and
we're running out of time but definitely
the if you think about I don't know how
familiar you are with the blockchain and
Bitcoin but basically it's there are two
ways that it works so there's one way
where every interaction is displayed for
the world but there's another way in
which several entities have to approve
the release of the private data in this
case it's digital currency but the only
way that well theoretically the only way
that someone can know that that
information is connected to you
is if you provide a highly encrypted
piece of information that several other
people have to approve in order for the
person on the other side to have access
to it so my pessimistic side says I
think the cats out of the bag for data
that's already out there but there is
some my optum the optimist in me which
is a lot bigger says that there is
actually a future where we can't protect
our privacy and more meaningful ways so
with that I will close out thank you so
much for your attention and I'd love to
talk to you after if you're interested